Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by Dr. Benjamin Saltzman. He's professor
of English language and literature at the University of
Chicago, and today we're going to talk about his
book Turning Away the Poetics of an Ancient Gesture.
So Dr. Saltzman, welcome to the show. It's a
pleasure to everyone.
It's great to be here. Thanks for having me.
OK, so turning away, I mean, first of all,
what is it to turn away? What is it
to avert our gaze from something?
Well, Ricardo, it's a lot of different things and
one of the. One of the, the, the ways
that this book opens up into itself is by
exploring the different ways in which we turn away
and the different ways that artists have represented, um,
variations on this gesture, covering one's eyes, averting one's
gaze, turning one's back, um, looking away in a
lot of different, uh, across a lot of different
varieties. And And that's, that's how the book was
written and it's how I think the experience of
reading it, um, comes through, where you encounter one
variety of this gesture after another and with each
new instance, you begin to realize. First of all,
how frequently it appears in our world and and
in our aesthetic encounters, but also how many different
kinds of meaning this gesture carries, right? Sometimes it
signifies grief, sometimes it signifies shame, sometimes it signifies,
uh, remorse or internal struggles of all kinds or
disgust, um. Or embarrassment, uh, it signifies a lot
of different things and I'm sure we'll talk about,
um, we'll talk, we'll get a chance to talk
about them today. But, um, just to start, I
think that's the, that's the kind of premise of
the book and one of the things that, um,
I hope readers will take away from it is,
is a kind of realization and an ability to
notice this gesture in the world around us.
But I mean these different kinds of situations or
different kinds of manifestations of turning away that I'm
going to ask you about in a bit. I
mean, do you see that they vary culturally, I
mean in terms of the gesture itself or in
terms of how we use our Hands to cover
our eyes or just turn our gaze away or
perhaps even move our bodies away or something like
that. Uh, I, I mean, does it vary cross
culturally or do you see that, for example, uh,
in Western culture, because I would imagine that is
the one you're focusing the most on here. That
over time perhaps the gesture acquired different meanings and
even, I mean, because we're going to talk about
artistic depictions of turning away throughout our conversation, do
you think that perhaps some of those meanings are
just we in our more modern times, sometimes perhaps
if inadvertently trying to impose an interpretation in terms
of the emotions and what the meaning of the
gesture when applied to perhaps ancient depictions of it.
I mean, what, what, what ideas do you have
about all of that?
Yeah, so this is, this is your, your question
gets at the heart of, you know, what is
it about this particular gesture, right? When, when someone
covers their, their face or cover that covers their
eyes, um, removes their face from the vision of
others, what is it about that gesture that, that
differs from other gestures? Um, AND how does it
differ across cultural context? How does it differ across,
you know, different works of art or Different, um,
references of poetry. How does it differ between antiquity,
um, and the present day? And that's something that
I'm very interested in is the way that this
gesture resonates and changes over time. Um, THE way
that our encounters with this gesture today, uh, are
energized by the historical past in which this gesture
has, has developed a wide variety of meanings. So
I'll I'll kind of answer your question theoretically, and
then I'll um maybe use it as a way
to dive into the structure of the book and
kind of share one story. Um, SO, theoretically, one
of the interesting things about this gesture is that
it, it ranges on a spectrum between The instinctive
and the performative, right? So it's, it's both, um,
a way in which we respond to something, uh,
you know, presented before us that we find disgusting
or unappealing, and we, we kind of can't control
how we respond in those moments. We turn away,
we cover our eyes, we, we can't bear to
look. But it's also a gesture that is, uh,
and can be performative, right? We can perform the
act of covering our eyes before others as a
way to, you know, hyper-aware of our, uh, sociality
and our, our relation to others, there being an
audience, for instance, for this gesture. Um, AND that's
quite unusual, the way in which it, it can
move between those two things and the difficulty of
Determining that from the outside, right? The difficulty of
ascertaining whether someone is covering their eyes as a
performance or as a kind of instinctive response to
something disgusting or unappealing or troubling or disturbing. So,
the way, uh, I mean, the best way to,
to, uh, begin to think about the, the burden
that it places on the interpreter, the one who
beholds this gesture, right, who encounters it in the
world or in a work of art, um, occurs
in, in the first chapter of the book. And
so I'll, I'll just say that the book is
structured. Around 5 chapters and each chapter begins with
a particular ancient or medieval or archaic scene in
which a figure covers their face or turns away.
Um, AND then it follows this scene as it
refracts around a kind of concept, and we'll talk
about some of those concepts, um, but also across
time. And as each chapter in the book progresses,
each chapter becomes progressively more wide ranging. And so,
whereas the, the kind of the, the, the second
chapter, for instance, after the introduction is very tightly
focused on a, on a particular scene, and it's
kind of constantly turning back to that scene, by
the time you get to the end of the
book, we're, we're rang. Really, really widely and in
unexpected ways, but you can see how the, the
aesthetic and effective energy of this gesture kind of
travels through, through time. So I'll, I'll just start
with the first chapter as an example, which is
it takes as its ancient scene, this famous painting
by Timanthe, and the original painting doesn't survive. It's
a depiction of um Agamemnon's sacrifice of his daughter
Iphigenia. And um the original painting doesn't survive. A
copy of it or something, you know, a work
thought to be similar to the original does survive
from Pompeii and is currently held in in the
Naples Archaeological Museum. Um, BUT the reason this painting,
in spite of not surviving, the reason it's so
famous is because Um, ancient rhetoricicians like Quin Quintillian,
Cicero, Pliny the Elder, they all wrote about it
and they wrote about the artist's decision to cover
Agamemnon's face, to cover the father's face. Um, WHY,
why did the painter need to cover his face
in that moment in which he's sacrificing his own
daughter? And the explanation they gave, um, was that.
The paintbrush would have been inadequate to the task
of representing such an extreme state of emotional intensity,
right? The father's grief, the loss, the anticipation of
loss, the, um, the kind of wavering uncertainty, right?
It's not an easy decision. He doesn't, uh, sort
of commit to it wholeheartedly. He goes back and
forth and tries to stop the sacrifice, but then
eventually is forced to, uh, to go through with
it. And so, um, Why, why cover the face?
Because there's no way the artist could have represented
such an extreme state of emotion. So right from
the start, we see how this gesture in which
a figure is covering their face, um, gets at
the very limits of artistic representation, right? Um, IT
runs up against the most extreme forms of emotional
intensity. Um, AND to get back to the heart
of your question, it puts The reason it's so
effective is because it puts the burden on the
viewer, the viewer of the work of art, to
imagine what that person is going through, to imagine
what Agamemnon is feeling, and, uh, makes the effect
all the more effective. Um, AND so, uh, so
yeah, so that, that I think is a One
way, right, in which this gesture, uh, kind of
sparks the imagination, right? PROVOKES the imagination.
Mhm. But I mean, when it comes to artistic
depictions, wouldn't you agree, I mean, if you don't,
uh, it's fine, but wouldn't you agree that there's
always at least an element of uncertainty when it
comes to, uh, the way we interpret what the
artist was trying to convey, I mean, not only
emotionally, but perhaps even in terms of the meaning
of the gesture in, in that particular context and
so on.
Yeah, absolutely. And I mean, in fact, you know,
later, later critics, 17th, 18th century critics often said,
you know what, like those ancient rhetoricicians were wrong.
This artist was just a really bad, really bad
painter, right? If he had any skill, he could
represent the emotion. So, so yes, there's, it's open
to debate, but, but also, um, You know, crucially
to your point, and, and another aspect of your
original question was about cultural specificity or the specificity
of the gesture, right? Does this gesture covering the
face, turning away, does it carry specific meaning in
a specific cultural context, um, or does it sort
of, uh, Does the variety of the gesture, does
its meaning from one context carry over into another
and influence, say, how we interpret it in a
work of art uh in a, in a totally
different context, if we've say previously encountered it in,
um, in one cultural context, right? And that's one
thing that I'm interested in is the overlap and
the way that there's a kind of fuzziness around
it, but I'm also very interested in The cultural
specificity of the gesture and the contextual specificity of
the gesture. So there's kind of two things going
on, right? One is that I'm pushing against a
particular way of a very influential and very important
way, one in which my book is heavily indebted
and which has been the basis for important moves
in the wider field of, of the history of
ideas and the history of Uh, of, uh, of
emotions, really, um, is that we tend to study
the history of emotions through a particular emotion, right?
So we tend to say, I'm, I'm interested in
studying the history of shame, and then, um, I
would study the history of shame and I would
look back, um, into the period that I'm studying
and I might encounter a gesture like the one
that that I'm describing and, and say, look, there's
an Example of shame because that's what I'm interested
in. And this is an oversim simplification, right? Because
again, I'm kind of working from a lot of
these important studies. But what I noticed is that
there's also a way in which that predetermines how
you interpret this particular gesture and the ambiguity of
this gesture is such that Um, it can also
represent grief or pity or, um, these different negative
affects, even positive effects as well, which we can
maybe talk about. But, um, but when you start
from the gesture, you kind of Really begin to
notice its ambiguity. Um, AND that's, that's not to
say, crucially, that it isn't that it doesn't carry
specific cultural or specific historical, um, meaning. And I'll
give just an example of that, which, um, was
a kind of discovery or realization that I made
fairly late in the project, right? It was maybe,
um, yeah, sort of a year or two before
it was done. And I had been working on
the, the 4th chapter is about the crucifixion of
Christ, and it takes images of the crucifixion and,
and, um, notices all the different ways in which
figures around the crucifixion cover their, cover their faces.
Um, AND this goes back to, for instance, um,
At the moment of the crucifixion, there's believed to
be an eclipse or a sort of sudden darkness
covering the earth. And the way that medieval artists
often represented this darkness was by depicting personified figures
above Christ, two personified figures above Christ representing the
sun and the moon, and those figures were covering
their faces. So that indicates a kind of, oh,
it's dark. The atmosphere is dark. How? Because these
figures are covering their faces. Um, AND that gesture
gets reproduced then below with, for instance, Mary beside
Christ covering her face in grief, um, or John
covering his face less frequently, but occasionally covering his
face. The, the frescoes in the convent of San
Marco in Florence by Franica are fantastic represent instances
of this where, um, there's so many figures. Um,
BESIDE these, these brilliant images of, of Christ's crucifixion
with, with the, the kind of metallic sparkling blood
catching your attention, and there are figures beside Christ
who are covering their faces quite deliberately, um, and
so that chapter kind of runs with that idea
and then, and then sees how, for instance. Um,
Marc Chagall in the 20th century, the, the, uh,
Russian painter Marc Chagall, who had a famous series
of paintings based, uh, uh, crucifixion paintings in which
he represented Christ as a Jewish figure, um, being
persecuted, and these were produced, most, most of them
were produced in 1938, um. So the, the kind
of urgency of the moment was, was demanding this
kind of, this kind of provocative work in which
the, uh, in which Christ is represented as a,
as a Jew. And what I noticed is that
in a lot of these paintings, there are figures
beside Christ who are covering their face, including one
self-portrait that uh Chagall paints in which he himself
is painting, um, uh, a, a. You know, a
canvas featuring the crucifixion of Christ and the painter
is turning away from Christ and covering his face.
And what I, what I noticed was that they're
often, these figures are often using their right hand.
Um, AND that carries specific significance, um, for, uh,
in a Jewish context because that's the hand that
Jews use to cover their eyes when they're saying
the Shama, the prayer, um, recited twice daily, um,
but also in moments before a loved one passes.
And so it's that kind of realization that, oh,
in this, in this work of art. The right
hand covering the face is very, very specific and,
and significant in and of itself. So I hope
that gives a sense of how like there's a
kind of ambiguity around the gesture that it can
mean a lot of different things. It can mean,
you know, Mary's grief or John's grief, but also
a kind of spiritual blindness because Christ is uh
human but divine and, and therefore, you know, can
we see Him? Can we not? How do you,
how does an artist represent it, right? So it,
it can mean all these different things, but then
also it can. Carry a very, very specific meaning.
Um, AND the, the shama, the right hand, um,
in Chagall's paintings is a perfect example of that.
Yeah, yeah, and that I guess is an example
that really points to what I was alluding to
before when it comes to the cultural context where
a particular turning away kind of uh gesture is
expressed, right, because in that case, since it's Jewish,
Jewish people doing it with their right. And it
has that particular kind of meaning, but if it
was just me using my right hand to cover
my face, it's just because I'm right-handed. I mean,
it wouldn't have any, the, the being the right
hand itself in my case, wouldn't have a particular
meaning. It was just because I, it's my dominant
hand and I tend to use it to.
Right. And that's, and that gets back to that,
the, the fact that this gesture is, you know,
sometimes it's instinctive, right? It's your right hand that
comes up to your face because that's the hand
you use. Other times it's more performative. It's your
right hand because that is the hand that you've
practiced using while saying the shama. And I actually,
I was giving a, um, like a bookstore event
a while ago and, and I will sometimes invite.
Uh, MY audience to cover their face, just to
feel, uh, and I, I might do the same
to your, your audience listening at home, right? Like,
take a moment and, and put your hand over
your face, touch your face, cover your eyes, close
your eyes, turn your head, uh, see how it
feels. Um, NOTICE, notice what that feels like. And
I did this in in an event and then
afterwards was talking to, um, one of the, the
audience members who was, um, you know, formerly a
kind of Orthodox Jew practicing regularly, and she said
that she noticed. That she instinctively put her right
hand to her face and while I was talking,
she kind of was reflecting on the fact that,
oh my gosh, here I am, you know, saying
the shama, um, just habitually. Um, SO there's, again,
there's even, even in those what could be deemed
a kind of performative mode of the gesture where
you're deliberately say, using your right hand because it
holds cultural significance and it carries meaning that you're
trying to activate. Uh, IT can also be habituated.
It can also be instinct instinctive in a way,
or, or not quite instinctive, but habituated at least.
Yeah, even though now that I'm thinking about it,
maybe if I wanted to turn away from something
that was more on my left periphery, I would
probably use my left hand. So you know, I
don't know, I would have to be exposed to
different kinds of situations and, and really be conscious
about it
to, and that's the thing is that we're often,
we're often not conscious about it, and this is,
this is the This was the experience of writing
the book, and I, you know, I think. Um,
YOU begin to, once you are alerted to the
prevalence of this gesture and the meaning that it
can carry. You begin to see it everywhere and
you begin to notice yourself, um, you begin to
notice yourself doing it in different ways and you
begin to think about the differences between the ways
that you do it, your left hand, your right
hand, or, or, you know, in a mode of
embarrassment or in a mode of disgust or, um,
whatever, but, but you begin to become hyper-aware of
how this gesture plays out in our, in our
lives and the variety of ways that it does.
OK, so then let's talk about the here the
varieties that we can find when it comes to
this kind of gesture and what it can express.
So what different kinds of situations have you found
lead us to turn away from something or someone?
Where to start? Where to start. Um, I think
one of the. I'll start with that. I,
I, I mean maybe we can only cover some
of the main ones, of course, because the variety
I would imagine would be very, very large,
so yeah. Well, I'll start with the, the kind
of a surprise maybe, um, which is just the,
that. The most surprising. Um, LET'S say the most
surprising meaning that I found in, in this gesture
in writing this book. Was that, you know, we
tend to think of turning away or looking away
as a mode of um inattention of we, we
associate it with indifference, with um disconnectedness or distance.
Right, if I'm turning away, I'm trying to produce
distance between me and the thing that I'm turning
away from. But the most surprising thing that I
found is that often in these works of art,
I can talk about some of them, um. Poets,
philosophers, they often call this gesture up. In moments
of profound engagement, in moments that that uh a
figure or a person is grappling with the most
difficult aspects of our world, um, and is struggling
with their own relation to those, those, those things.
And so. Um, YOU know, I mentioned the, the
Frangelio frescoes in the convent of San Marco, for
instance, alongside the crucifixion of Christ. What, you know,
the figures who are covering their faces in those
frescoes are not covering them because they're being inattentive
to the scene. No, on the contrary, those are
some of the most, those are the figures that
when you, when you encounter them on the wall,
you, you kind of recognize that they are deeply
engaged. Deeply proximate to the pain of that moment.
Um, AND how does an artist represent that with,
you know, other than with this gesture, and, and
it made me realize that, you know, sometimes kind
of a wide-eyed, you know, constant, constant mode of
attention is not in fact the most, uh, meaningful
way to pay attention that sometimes we need to
process the world around us by taking a moment
to, to. Uh, TO turn away in order to
pay better attention, um, in order to reflect, in
order to act, and just as an example of
that, it, it is, uh, uh, there's a famous
painting by, um, Francisco Goya, the 3rd of May.
Um, YOU, you know this painting. I'm, I'm sure
it features, um. Uh, A figure who's about to
be executed, his arms, he's wearing a white shirt.
His arms are outstretched. Um, IT'S a very kind
of crucifixion-like scene, and the, uh, the soldiers are
lined up with their backs to the viewer of
the painting and their rifles pointed at the, at
the victim. And then around the victim who is
about to be executed are several other figures, compatriots
who are um. Looking in various directions, but some
of them, 2, I think, maybe 3, are, are
covering their, covering their eyes. Uh, AND I really
think that those, you know, if those figures weren't
there, you wouldn't feel the same degree of intensity.
You wouldn't feel the same degree of weight. Um,
AND it's those figures who, who can't bear to
look in that moment, whether because of fear or
terror or, um, or sort of anticipatory grief or
distress or whatever, um, it's the fact that they're
covering their eyes that provokes us as we look
ourselves at this painting to feel its weight because
they are there and cannot bear to look. So,
yeah, I hope that, I hope that gives a
sense of um some of the variety, but I'm
sure, yeah, I'm sure there are others. What, what
came to mind to you? Yeah,
I mean, I mean, I, I was thinking, uh,
also not so much about the situation itself, but
more about the variety in terms of the ways
or how we gesture to other people that we
are turning away. I mean that it can be
just covering our eyes or covering part of our
eyes or covering our face or, for example, I
don't know, turning. Our entire body another direction or
for example, or I guess that also when we're
trying to signal to other people to keep themselves
away because we don't want them near us, we
just extend our arm like this with the palm
facing them or something like that
right or even a or even a very subtle,
you know, a very almost unnoticeable except to ourselves.
Way of, of averting our, our eye, right, averting
our gaze and, and. Yeah, there, I mean, there's
a huge range, and there's an implicit in one
of your examples. Is a way of a way
in which we sometimes cover our eyes while still
trying to look. Right? We, we are in, in
a sense performing this gesture because we don't want
other people to see us looking, but we still
want to look, um, right, we do this when
we Maybe drive down the road and and pass
an accident and we know that or we think
that we shouldn't be looking but we want to
look and so we kind of waver back and
back and forth, um,
even though when it comes to that particular situation,
sometimes people are very shameless about it and they
just look reckless.
Exactly, yeah, and then themselves get into into an
accident. Um, BECAUSE they weren't looking where they should
have been looking or whatever, I
was, I was also thinking that perhaps, and this
of course is getting more into the effective or
emotional aspect of it, and we can talk more
about it in a bit, but for example, uh,
many times when there's a homeless person, a beggar
on the street, and people just want to pass
by them. I mean, without, of course they notice
them, but they are trying to signal to other
people that they are not really noticing them, so
they just look another direction. They avert their gaze.
I mean, it's, it's sort of, it's as if
people are saying that, OK, if I look directly
at the beggar, then I mean, since there are
Other people around, I am expected to do something
to give them money, to give them a coin
or a bill or something like that. But if
we just avert our gaze, it's as if we
are also suppressing or avoiding our shame or guilt,
right, because, because if we're just not looking there,
then I don't need, I don't need to do
anything.
Yeah, and I, I mean, this is, you're, you're
right, having never myself been unhoused, right, I can
only imagine the, the difficulty of, of, um, of
life under, under those conditions and And yet it's
something that I think many of us face when
we, when we walk down the street, we encounter
that maybe that realization, um, maybe we Prefer not
to encounter it and try to avoid thinking about
it, but, um, I guess I'm, I'm interested in,
in what that What that feels like when we,
when we do decide to avert our gaze or
habitually decide habituate habituatedly avert our gaze in those
moments. Um, AND the, the different Reasons we might
give to ourselves for doing so, as you, as
you just elucidated, right? Is it because I'm feeling
shame? Is it because I want to be respectful
of, uh, of this person I'm encountering? And yet,
so much, um, uh, sort of advocacy around the
unhoused. Has to do with visibility and the feeling
by contrast of the invisibility that the unhoused often,
often feel. Um, MY, my, I had an uncle
who, uh, recently passed away who lived in, in
Arkansas and, and, um. Gave his, I mean, he
was such a, a warm-hearted person. Um, HE would
always, he, he was obsessed with like the essential
oils and, and the color blue. Like you need
to wear the color blue because if you're not,
you're, you're gonna, you know, it'll mess with your,
your brain chemicals in negative ways. But anyways, but
he was, he was, he gave his life to,
to caring for the unhoused and essentially sort of
welcomed. He, he, um, built communities and he welcomed
them into his own home and, and, um, and
it really became a kind of full commitment. Um,
AND it made me wonder, you know, in, in
your question, like, what does it mean to fully
commit to, to caring for, for the unhoused, um,
and maybe that's also part of why. We Avert
our avert our eyes because we can't commit to,
to that kind of wholehearted care or, or whatever.
But there's, but there's also people who, who don't,
uh, do that.
Yeah, yeah, and I, yeah, I guess that when
it comes to homeless people, they must experience a
lot of turning away from other people because that,
that sentiment of being or feeling invisible in society
is something that they express quite a lot. And
for example, I remember reading a book about Diogenes,
the cynic, and while he was homeless inside these
vases. In Athens, he would, uh, I mean, he
would beg his statues to train himself to be
turned down by by other people when he begged
for money because, I mean, it's really hard psychologically
to, uh, I mean, have that kind of need
and constantly being ignored by other people.
And I, and I think An important distinction just
to kind of take the picture out a little
bit broader to a wider range of circumstances, but
I think there's a really important distinction between something
like indifference. And um, And the different ways in
which we, we look away, um, and the, the
reason I want to make that distinction is because
the two often get conflated, right? We often say
here, yeah, we often hear and say things like,
don't look away from this atrocity, from this corruption,
from, um, The, the suffering on the street or
the suffering abroad, don't look away. And what we
mean by that is, don't be indifferent. Right? Don't
be indifferent to it and maybe even to take
it a step further, do something about it. Um,
AS, as hard as that is to, to conceive,
what, what should I do, right? Is a question
that we then kind of naturally face. And, and
I, and I kind of want to disambiguate those,
those two things because. In the in when we
find ourselves. Actively turning away or looking away, um,
two things happen. One, Is that we. Don't get
rid of the, we don't sort of avoid the,
the sight of the thing that we're turning away
from, right? The act of turning away happens too
late. We've already seen it, right? Um, AND, or,
or at the very least, we've anticipated it, right?
Oh, I'm going to see something that I don't
want to see, so I'm going to turn away.
But now I'm thinking about it. Um, AND as
a result, what I began to notice is that
when we turn away, it actually signals, oftentimes signals
to us that the thing that we're turning away
from. It is significant. It warrants our reflection. It
warrants our action. It warrants our intervention, perhaps, but
that impulse, that human impulse to be repulsed by,
um, a, a horrific sight, that's, that's a crucial
signal that we, I don't think it makes sense
to try and avoid. Um, BUT instead we should
pay attention to, we should notice when we find
ourselves turning away and then ask ourselves why, why
am I turning away? And that's kind of what
I've found in my, in my own experience is
just that when I have turned away, when I
have been repulsed by something to the point where
I think I can't, I can't look at this
anymore. I don't forget it. I mean that it,
it becomes lodged in my mind along with my
own inability to look my own act of turning
away. And, um, and I think that's in, in
many ways, that's the opposite of indifference. That's the
opposite of I don't care. I like, I find
myself still dwelling on those moments, um. And in
in this era in which we encounter suffering so
readily on our phones on a daily basis, minute
to minute, one thing after the next. Indifference seems
to be um. Very much sort of we're, we're
kind of on the brink or already over the
point in which indifference is, is becoming more and
more of a problem and more and more prevalent.
Um, AND so I, I wonder, you know, what
does it mean to, to actually lean into those
feelings when you, when you find yourself completely, uh,
facing the unbearable, right? To actually recognize it as
unbearable and Uh, and take a moment to, to
reflect on it and maybe think about what kind
of action, uh, might, uh, be sort of, what
kind of action you might take in response. I,
right? But, um,
Uh, do you think, yeah, uh, do you think
that, uh, then because you were mentioning repulsion, do
you think that sometimes turning away can be a
gesture that is a behavioral response to the emotion
of disgust, of feeling disgusted by something?
I think so, yeah, abso absolutely. That is one
of the, the sort of distance creating ways that
we, that we respond to something that, um, That
produces disgust in us. But you know, earlier you
asked about, you know, you've asked about varieties, right?
And um. One of the things that I think
has happened is that the. Rhetoric of looking away,
um, as is typical of the way that rhetoric
works, right? It, it has become metaphorized. It's become
a metaphor for indifference, but it's also taken on
these different forms. So for instance, scrolling on our
phones, right? Is that paying attention, right? It can
feel in some ways it can feel like, oh,
I need to be paying attention to the, to
the affairs of the world and, and this is
one way in which I do it. And so
I scroll on my phone through a news feed
or through social media and encounter kind of news
about the world and, and, hey, I'm paying attention.
Um. That seems anathema to human flourishing and in
fact, doom scrolling or scrolling past, right, is just
a kind of extension of looking away. It's another
form of looking away, or at least we, I
think we tend to think about it in those
terms. Um, AND so that I hope gives the
sense of the way that You know, yes, we
have a very specific literal, um, form of this
gesture in which, you know, a figure on this
in a work of art, um, covers their eyes
with their hands. Great. But it also takes on
kind of metaphorical meanings and can take on different
shapes and forms up to the point of, say,
scrolling past an image on your phone. Um.
And do you think that it can also be
a gesture to express rejection? I mean, rejection, rejecting
someone, I mean, for depending on the context, it
can, it can be different forms of rejection, but
basically just signaling to the other person that, uh,
yeah, I'm not going along with what you asked
me to do or I don't care about you
anymore or something like that.
Yeah. Yeah, it can, it can mean that too.
It can, it can also signify respect, right? So
and that's, again, that's the kind of complexity of
this way of relation is that it, depending on
the context, right, it can, it can be a
mode of rejection, of distancing of, you know, to
go back to disgust, disgust, but it can also
be a mode of Respect or remorse, right? Even
a sort of regret an introspection, a kind of
realization of one's own, uh, self or one's own
wrongs or one's own relation to others. So it,
um, you know, why someone is turning away, is
it turning away in order to turn inward or
is it turning away because of, uh, as a
way to reject someone else. Um, AND, and from
the outside, it's very hard to tell.
Do you think that it can also manifest a
reaction to fear or to avoid something that we
expect to provoke fear in us, because actually, I
mean, averting our gaze is also something that people
can do in a very basic context of, for
example, what Watching a horror movie, I mean, we,
we know that the, the, the sin that will
provoke fear is coming, and some people, I mean,
particularly the ones who don't like horror movies particularly,
many times just close their eyes or avert their
case or something.
Well, there's a great, yeah, yeah, there, I mean,
there are, there are a lot of people who
don't, uh, who sort of can't watch horror and
therefore say like know and know this about themselves,
right? Um, WHICH is also very interesting, right, that
you kind of know your own limits or you've
maybe had some trauma in your past that that
alerts you to the fact. I mean, this is
why we have the sort of content warnings at
the at the beginning of TV shows and stuff,
right? Because, um, Many of us know what our
triggers are and, and want to protect ourselves from,
from those, uh, kinds of experiences. But even there's
a, um, this great moment in, uh, In Hitchcock,
just to talk about horror for a second, in
Hitchcock's Psycho, um, you know, there's the, the famous
shower scene, right, which we've all seen, even if
you haven't, you know, watched Psycho, um, but immediately
after that shower scene, um, Norman Bates comes. Down
from the house and uh runs into the, the
motel room. And this is the scene in which
he then cleans up the mess and he runs
into the bathroom. Sees what he sees, um, and
keep in mind that this, this scene is, is
in a very Hitchcockian way it's, it has primed
us to notice the different kind of modes of
visuality at play, right? So, um. The, the, the
previously the, the blood is circling the drain, the
drain then fades into, uh, and, and, uh, transitions
into a shot of, um, uh, of the sort
of the eye, right? And, um, and so we're,
we're made to pay attention to sight in this
moment. And Norman Bates then walks into the, the
runs into the bathroom and immediately gasps, pulls back,
turns his back to the wall and covers, brings
his hand to his mouth in in shock and
awe. Oh my gosh, right? What have I just
seen? And it's, it's a kind of perplexing moment,
a surprising moment, but it also feels like a
very natural response to the sight of the, the
sort of scene of a murder. Um, AND I
think that's characteristic of horror is that it's meant
to make you want to look, to make you
want to look carefully. You're intrigued, you're drawn in,
um, but also to kind of provoke the, the.
Precisely the feeling of, of horror, right?
Yeah, but, but even the the the scene, the
shower scene itself, it's interesting because I mean it
could be argued that it's in itself, it contains
an element of turning away because I mean we
know of course what happened, but we don't see
it happening, it's just implied by seeing the blood
running down the bathtub
and but Marianne Crane has seen. What has happened,
you know, Marion Crane has seen the, the, the
murderer, um, up close, and, and that's why, you
know, that, that. Transition from the, the drain to
her eye, it, it, it reminds us, oh, she's
seen something and, and, um, yeah, I mean, I
could go on and on about this. It's a
really fascinating scene, but it, it does, I think
Hitchcock there is playing with our desire to look
and our desire to turn away and the kind
of ambivalence between those two. In fact, there's again,
like kind of classic Hitchcock, there's two, Drawings of
birds on the wall. There's two kind of framed,
uh, drawings of birds, um, which, uh, Bates knocks
down one of them and then at the end
of the scene, he, he kind of notices it
on the ground and he picks it up and
rehangs it and you realize that one of the
birds is facing towards the bathroom and the other
is facing away, right? So it's, again, that's like
Hitchcock is aware of, of the way in which
horror drives us to look, but also to look
away.
Yeah, but, but for example, you can contrast it
with that initial scene in Halloween where Michael Myers
as a child stabs his own sister because we
see the stabbing there, but we don't see the
stabbing in Psycho, so it, I mean it's, it's
so, so there, it's not, there's not an element
of turning away unless of course you close your
eyes while the movie is playing or something like
that, so. You know,
Yeah, yeah. Well, and that's, that's another question is
like, what gets, what gets shown to us, you
know, again, to kind of take a step back
from the particular to a more theoretical question, which
is to say, you know, sometimes we have a
lot of agency over what we turn away from
or what we look at, what we choose to
look at. Um, BUT other times, We're, we're either.
Sort of Uh, we're rather sort of given things
to look at that we have no, no, very
little control over. Maybe we can turn away, but
it's too late, um, or the things that we
encounter have been kind of predetermined for us or
certain things are not shown to us, um, and,
you know, this is becoming a much more complicated
and in some ways interesting question with the power
of algorithms, um. And, uh, you know, determining what,
what it is that we see on our social
media feed and the order in which we see
it and um and how that's designed to basically
retain our retain our attention. Um.
Yeah, so I mean, let, let me ask you
about certain particular depictions of turning away. I mean
some of them more written by philosophers or explored
by philosophers and theologians and others, more artistic depictions
of it, so. Uh, YOU, you, because in the
book you explore, for example, Saint Augustine's confession. So
where can we find, where can we find this
gesture of exploration of the gesture of turning away
in that particular work?
Yeah, so I, so I mentioned earlier that each
chapter starts with an archaic scene. Um, AND the
chapter that begins with a scene from St. Augustine's
confessions, um, it's a chapter about sensation, right? The
question behind it is, you know, what is it
about sight that is capable of being turned away
that the other senses are. Uh, NOT, not as
sort of capable of, of shutting down. It's, it's
much harder to shut down our hearing, for instance.
So what is the difference between sight and hearing?
Um, AND to provoke this question. I raised this
moment in, in Augustine's confessions where he is writing
about his friend Alypius, who has had this problem.
He's addicted to going to the gladiator games, the
circus, the insanity of the circus. And, um, he,
uh, eventually gives up this addiction, and Augustine is
quite proud of, of this development. And he gives
it up until one day, uh, after lunch, he's
walking with his friends in Rome and they, they
come across the amphitheater. And they all want to
go in and they, they drag him in. And
he says, you can, you can drag me in,
you can force me in, but you can't make
me look. I'm going to keep my eyes shut.
And he succeeds at keeping his eyes shut until
a particularly gruesome moment causes the crowd to erupt.
And when the crowd erupts, the sound enters Alypius's
ears, and it provokes his curiosity, and it, and
it opens, and he opens his eyes, and he
gulps up the gore, and he just, you know,
uh, soaks it all up. And Augustine writes, you
know, if only he could shut his ears as
well. So there's something about, there's something about, um,
sound that is, that is, uh, that sort of
permeates, um, our senses, um, that, uh, is not
as susceptible to, to being shut down or or
closed off. And Augustine recognized this, and he also
had, and it kind of, and it and it
fits in in a very complicated way to his
theories of sensation. So he had various theories about
the different ways in which the soul governs our
senses. And so for instance, sight was thought to
be a very active sense, so was hearing. Um,
SIGHT was believed to be powered by rays that
sort of exit the eyes and then, uh, rebound
from the object that we're seeing and, and give
us information about what it is that we're seeing.
And in that sense, that it's, it's governed or
thought to be governed by the intent of the
soul, the intention of the soul. Hearing was much
more complicated because it's obviously generated by sort of
vibrations in the world around us. And so what
is the role of the soul in encountering sound?
Do we actually control what sounds we hear? And
that's kind of for us and that's the problem.
That's the problem with like song, right, is that
it can infiltrate our senses. And we, you know,
this comes back to the last thing that we're
discussing, like, we actually have very, we have little
control over that, right? It, it has a tendency
to Um, to, to, to permeate us and, and
influence us. So, um, so yeah, and then it
becomes. Interesting, um, this, this story of Alypius, because
Olivia shows up again in the final, the kind
of climactic moment in the confessions where Augustine is
undergoing his conversion, and conversion is an interesting word
because it, it means to turn with or to
turn towards, as opposed to, for instance, aversion, uh,
to turn away. Aversion is to turn away, conversion
is to turn with or to turn towards, in
this case, to turn towards God, um, and In
that moment of conversion, Alypius is there with, um,
with Augustine, and, um, there's a, there's, there's a
lot going on, but um there's a a famous
representation of this moment by, again, the painter Fra
Angelico. Where Augustine is in his Milanese garden undergoing
this moment of conversion and how does Fra Angelico
represent him, but with his hands, his head in
his hands, um, and again, that gesture, it just
points in so many different directions at this moment.
He's on the one hand, he's weeping under this
fig tree. Right. On the other hand, he's in
a state of, uh, uh, of sort of spiritual
darkness, a state of ambivalence, a state of confusion,
a state of wavering, a state of sensory disorientation,
uh, a moment in which he's trying to turn,
turn off his outer senses and turn inward towards
his inner senses. And so, Um, just the, the
speed with which I, I kind of surveyed those
different meanings gives you a sense of how, you
know, this one gesture in this one work of
art can point to so many different details in
Augustine's own narrative of that moment of conversion, um,
which entails, um, entails all of these different kinds
of, of relation. And in that painting, Alypius is
painted in the background, kind of looking away from
Augustine. He's shielding his, his eye with his eyes
with his hand.
Mhm. How about the case of, uh, Michelangelo's fall
and expulsion of Adam and Eve from the, the
Garden for the Garden of Eden? I mean, what
kind of depiction of, uh, turning away can, uh,
do we find there?
Yeah, so, so the last chapter of the book.
I'll just, let me, I'll I'll like bring us
there by, you know, the first chapter starts with
Timanthes' sacrifice of Iphigenia. The second chapter, um, looks
at this moment in Plato's Republic where Socrates just
tells the story of Leontius who encounters a pile
of corpses next to the executioner and and turns
away and then covers his face as he struggles
with himself and then gives in. And condemns his
own eyes. Take your fill of that beautiful sight,
he says. Um, SO it's a kind of ambivalent
relation to these, to these corpses. And then the
third chapter is about sensation and Saint Augustine, which
I was just talking about. The 4th chapter is
about starts with the kind of crucifixion, and it's
about the way that this gesture represents darkness. I've
talked a little bit about that. And then the
final chapter starts with Adam and Eve and the
representations of Adam and Eve. And in many ways
this is where the project as a whole first
started. I, I was looking at a medieval manuscript,
um, containing a poetic translation of the Book of
Genesis, heavily illustrated, and I noticed that in these
illustrations, Adam and Eve are represented not only covering
their genitals, but also covering their eyes. Um, AND
to harken back to an earlier point in our
conversation, covering their eyes in a kind of partial
way. Their fingers are, are widespread such that they're
Uh, they're, they're kind of clearly able to see
through their hands. Um, AND it made me wonder,
you know, why, right? Why are they covering their
eyes when we're so used to seeing them at
the moment of the fall, having eaten the, the
fruit of the tree of the knowledge of knowledge
of good and evil. Why, why cover their eyes
when they are usually covering their genitals, right? And,
and that's what kind of set this project in
motion. And we often see this gesture, most, most
typically where we see it is, is not in
moments of the fall, but in the moments just
after, um, in the expulsion, in the expulsion from
paradise and the representation of that, uh, that moment
of displacement. And um there's a famous fresco by
Masaccio in in Florence where Adam and Eve are
being expelled from paradise and Adam has his hand
in or his face in his hand. Um, AND
in the, the Sistine Chapel, the Michelangelo, um, that
you, um, Ricardo were just referring to, uh, it's
a little bit different. They're not, they're not quite
covering their faces in that, in that moment. Um,
THE reason it, it begins to, I begin thinking
about that in the book is because there's another,
um, on the, on the back, on the sort
of back wall of the Sistine Chapel, there's the
condemned, the figure of the condemned man who's kind
of covering half of his face in, um, this.
Really kind of painful state of um of depredation.
Uh, BUT. It's this scene of Adam and Eve
being expelled from paradise that's on the on the
ceiling. It's one of the central panels on the
ceiling. And um. And Eve is looking back, right?
She's looking back towards paradise in this, in this
moment. And The one of the kind of themes
for this final chapter is the way that. Turning
away can sometimes entail a looking back again, a
kind of remorse, regret, a sort of backward lookingness,
retroversion, for instance. And here we see, uh, Eve
looking back as they're being expelled, as they're being
turned away from paradise. And when I was standing
in the Sistine Chapel thinking about this, I, I
realized that, and this is why it's so amazing
to, to stand before these great works of, of
art because they, This kind of experience makes you
realize things that you wouldn't encounter, um, in the
comfort of your home, uh, before your laptop. But
I, I was standing there looking up at, um,
at this panel, and it made, you know, my
neck started hurting. Right? And, and you realize that
there's no way to look at this panel, um,
where Eve's neck is contorted backwards in what looks
to be a very painful position. There's no way
for us to look at this panel without also
contorting our necks into quite a painful position. And
we can't look at it very long, um, even
if you stand in the sort of further furthest
corner of the, of the, uh, chapel. And, um,
and that's, that's quite remarkable how these works kind
of call on, it's a great example of the
way that um When you stand before a work
of art, it, it. Can provoke you to reflect
on your own position as a viewer, um, and
what that feels like and the feelings that it
arouses in you.
Yeah, so, OK, so do you, do you think
that perhaps the gesture of turning away can be
something that is induced by works of art and
that it would be something that at least some
artists try to induce on purpose or not?
Yeah, I think it, I mean, especially in a
visual. A work of visual art. I think it
does provoke us to reflect on our own, even
unconsciously. I mean, I think we often don't notice
those figures who are turning away within a work
of art, um, but their presence there, um, does
a lot of work. Um, BUT, but is, but
is that the end? I'm not sure. I mean,
I, I think one of the amazing things about
Writing this book and then being in conversation with
so many people has been the way that people
have responded by coming to me or writing to
me or um uh uh emailing me and saying,
writing old fashioned letters, in some cases, typewritten letters
saying, Have you thought about this instance of this
gesture in this other work of art and um.
On the one hand, that's, that's how this book
was written, right? It was written through, I didn't
mention this earlier, but it was written through conversations
with friends and colleagues, um, and, uh, who, who
would sort of, I tell them about what I
was writing about and they say, what about this
example? And then I'd run with that and I'd,
I'd, um, see where, where it would take me.
And that's continued even after the book has, you
know, been sealed between two covers, um, and that
to me is really exciting. So I, I would
actually invite your, your listeners to, you know, reach
out to me if, if you encounter. This gesture
somewhere in the world or in a work of
art or um in your life.
Yeah, sure. So let me just ask you one
last question. So I mean, how do you think
we should approach this kind of behavior and gestures
of turning away? I mean, do you think that
we should just, I mean, the way we should
approach them is just the way we did here
today. I mean, just exploring different instances where people
turn away different depictions of it and trying to
understand. The contexts, the situations where people do that
and the emotions that it could express or that
people might be feeling when they do that, or
do you think that we should condemn these gestures
in some way?
Yeah, it's no surprise after this conversation that I
think it's, it's probably counterproductive to condemn these gestures,
even though they feel. Like they're worthy of contempt,
um, and that they are modes of moral failure,
but I think they're far more complex and they
get to the, the heart of what it means
to be human, even if that heart might be
ugly, um, at times. And, um, so I think.
I guess one answer, and, and I don't think
it's the final answer, but I, I think one
answer is to begin to notice and, and pay
attention to this gesture in, in all of its
complexity, um, and to notice. In other words, rather
than avoiding it or outright condemning it, um. To,
to kind of recognize it's, it's range of, of
meaning, um, and recognize its capacity to, to shape
how we relate to others and how we, um,
inhabit the world and, and hopefully make it a
better place.
Yeah, and I mean, I guess just to comment
that I guess that in at least in certain
instances our ability or our wanting to turn away
can actually manifest. Some of our humanity in the
sense that, OK, so that what I'm turning away
from is so painful or so difficult to watch
or to contend with that I mean, I wouldn't
be able to bear it because I was also
thinking that for example nowadays, since, as you said
earlier, we are exposed so much and so continuously
on social media and the internet more generally to
Painful and violent things, maybe we can, there's a
risk that we can get to a point where
we are so desensitized that we no longer turn
away, but it's not because we are acknowledging that
we have to do something about that, but it's
just that we don't care about it anymore. Yeah,
looking, exactly looking without caring. Is not the, the
path forward, I think.
Yeah, OK, great, so the book is again turning
away the poetics of an ancient gesture, and of
course I will be leaving a link to it
in the description of the interview, and Dr. Saltzman,
uh, apart from the book, are there any places
on the internet where people can find you and
your work?
Um, ON the internet, I guess I, I'd, I'd
rather, I'd rather people spend time in a, in
a museum. Um, BUT, uh, but no, it's been
a real pleasure to, to be in conversation with
you, Ricardo. Yeah.
No, thank you so much for doing this. Thank
you so much for taking the time to come
on the show.
All right. Take care. Thanks for having me.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights, Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at lights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Mulleran, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolf, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andre, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarith, John Yardston, and Samuel
Cerri, Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezara Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punter DaRosmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alec Baka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabilpan Scortez
or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffyanny Smith, and
Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno, Luke
Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David Williams,
Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie
Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee Junior.
Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert Grassy,
Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark Kempel,
Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson, Benjamin
Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensleyman.
George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van Goler,
Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi, Perpendicular,
Janaertner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov, Sean Nelson,
Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special thanks to
my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank Lucas Stink, Tom
Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas Trumbull, Catherine
and Patrick Tobin, John Carlomon Negro, Al Nick Cortiz,
and Nick Golden, and to my executive producers, Matthew
Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie. Thank you
for all.